there's another damaging report tonight
in new york governor andrew cuomo's
nursing home scandal
top aides reportedly altered a state
health department report or pressured it
to be altered
to remove the true number of residents
who died from the coronavirus
correspondent aisha hosni has the latest
tonight from new york
i have not hidden anything
from the people of this state nearly a
year ago new york governor andrew cuomo
promised to lead the state through the
pandemic with transparency
tonight he faces a shocking claim he did
anything
but that the wall street journal reports
the governor's top advisors
convinced state health officials to
alter their report on nursing home
deaths
to only count deaths that occurred
inside the facilities
not patients who died after being taken
to the hospital
the governor's office says it did so
because it could not
verify those out of facility numbers the
wall street journal writes the changes
reveal that the state possessed a
fuller accounting of out-of-facility
nursing home deaths
as early as the summer of 2020. it
wasn't until
january of this year new york's attorney
general revealed the state
had under reported nursing home deaths
by as much as
50 percent 15 thousand new yorkers died
in nursing homes
their families unsurprised by the latest
blow
it's bittersweet when we get information
that we knew all along was
you know this is what it was the new
details are also raising eyebrows about
the timeline of events
the new york times reports just four
days after the release of that altered
report
cuomo was publicly commenting about
writing his book
preparing to cash in on his pandemic
achievements
white house press secretary jensaki
today pushed to comment
we've certainly seen those reports
obviously they're troubling
and we certainly would support any
outside investigation pressure is
mounting for cuomo to step down
andrew cummer doesn't have the
self-dignity to resign
he must be impeached as new details
emerge over sexual harassment claims
former aide charlotte bennett tells cbs
the governor
propositioned her for sex without
explicitly saying it
he implied to me that i was old enough
for him
and he was lonely
and shannon tonight state democrats are
calling for an
oversight hearing into that wall street
journal report
shannon aisha hosni in new york we'll
see you again
at 11 tonight thanks aisha